the people that are really trying to get
me are the ones that are auditing and I
use that like auditing the five so
they're actually like it's like they're
not taking the course you know they're
showing up in the back right I mean that
the professor uses the wrong pronoun and
that's that's what that's what I I
notice that it's more like so you know
like uh you know
I would assume that at least once a week
there is somebody deliberately trying to
destroy my career but I can't let that
stop me I have to I I've talked about
this in previous books we all have to
share the risk and I I and I have to
always I I'm not blowing smoke up your
ass but I have to say that you helped
destroy cancel Culture by monetizing the
act of being canceled
if you get canceled and there's another
way out you will always rise above
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the number one late night show host in
all of television as well as the author
of the brand new book The King of late
night Greg Gutfeld Gregory how are you
I am fantastic is it Gregory is it
gregford who what is it really I like
big G because I got a Dog Named Gus and
he's little G and I'm Big G is Gus with
you today yeah Gus is with me would you
like to see him I'd like to see Gus
because everything you're doing on
Instagram is Gus related give the people
what they want then we'll talk about
politics and media and all that nonsense
oh look at guys
look at Gussy Gus Gus you love me
he's like he's looking for food he's
looking at my manager uh who's a big
pushover Eric
all right well what Gus is welcome to
make as many guest appearances you are
the king of late night and the walk-on
the guest appearance is a big thing
before we do anything here at Gutfeld I
want to throw back to me you know you
were the first you on you were on our
first show yes what did you say so I
have to call you out for being because I
doubted you you what did you say in the
first show well first off before I tell
you that I just want to say on the off
chance that I say anything offensive
here during the Gutfeld exclamation
point program I just want to say I'm
doing Today's Show as a black lesbian
identifying as today but on the first
show the first Gutfeld show I was
sitting in this chair and I said you
would be the number one king in late
night within one year and Greg
I say no it's not possible
Gutfeld you did it even faster than I
said I got to give you credit man
um you are so certain that it was
happening I believe that you willed it
to happen right it's kind of like you
know when Scott Adams talks about
affirmations it was the secret it was
the secret you said it's going to happen
and you I think I might have been a
little reluctant and you said no no no
no no there's no way it can't happen and
it you looked basically you looked at
the environment and you were right that
there was this Gap and they were all
feet oh now he's back and they were
feeding off your wife what was that yes
okay he felt bad now there is the dog
that I know but you were right you're
right you hit it and then it I I was
gonna say it was going to take like a
year
but it was six months it was not even
six months all right now he's gonna go
that you got you got five seconds of Gus
there we got extra guts well you know
the thing is man it was obvious to me
because you you'd obviously been doing
it at the weekly but I'd done it a
million times it was it was and is fun
and you people always ask me about you I
get probably asked about you in terms of
what he's like off camera more than
anyone else uh because you know you're
sort of like right between corporate
press and and like online media so
everyone wants to know and it's like to
me it's like they turn on the camera you
are exactly the same you're having fun
it's kind of messy and how many people
even work for you you know the other
shows have what 50 60 80 people working
for them you got you got like two guys
well I mean over I mean if you if you
factor in crew uh 12 people 12 and I
mean like you can look at something like
Colbert I think it's like a couple of
hundred or uh let's just say it let's
just say a thousand a thousand you know
it's definitely a thousand people but I
I so it's it's roughly 12 of course we
do use the studios that are used for
other people so that's you know but uh
we have we have a small staff and
generally you're right I mean it's like
uh there's no reason for me to
differentiate between what I am
you know in the green room or at home
and what I am on the show I'm I'm 58 and
I know I don't look it thank you no you
look 56 honestly yeah I look like I look
a little smidge over 56. but um it's
like what's the point of working that
hard uh I got here
this way and and um and like I
I
I can't be I mean I don't even know I
wouldn't know what else to be so that
means if I find that a story sucks in
the middle of doing it I will say it
sucks
um if I lose my train of thought uh I
will say I lose my train of thought if I
say a joke and nobody laughs at it I'll
be like why are you laughing I'm not
going to I'm not going to sit there and
be talk show host guy because I I'm not
I mean I was I keep saying this to
people who say you're a comedian no I
wasn't I was running editorial meetings
for most of my career uh I think right
now I guess now I have as much on TV as
I did in publishing publishing I quit in
2004 so that was like 14 years and now
it's like probably like 13 years
how did you do that jump I actually I I
don't think I know how do you do the
jump from publishing you were doing you
were doing men's fitness right was it
men's fitness Men's Health Men's Health
sorry how do you make that jump to
that's like comparing Fox News to
Newsmax oh
how dare you sorry sorry actually you
know it's the irony of this and it's
like if you look backwards and try to
reverse engineer a career it's
impossible
but it had to do with me being
editor-in-chief of Maxim in London and
uh I was interviewed for something
called the black table by AJ delorio who
then got famous because of the uh Gawker
uh right right right right and it was a
really fun interview and Matt labash saw
it and Matt labash had been asked to be
an original blogger on The Huffington
Post and uh I think the Weekly Standard
wouldn't let him do it because Bill
Crystal's an and so
um he can fact check that the fact
checkers can fact check that very easy
to check but uh but so labash like said
dude you should do it you should do it I
could probably do it because Maxim
doesn't care and so they I they must
have sent that uh black table interview
and then I get hooked up and that's how
I met Breitbart and
um so there was like the first day that
the Huffington Post launched and
I was like seven eight hours ahead or
whatever and I wrote I treated The
Huffington Post like it was a online
bulletin that's done by your aunt so it
would be like a lost and found there's a
weird cat in my yard and stuff like that
so the first one was a a recipe for
lemon squares
and so so when the when the thing
launched they had like something maybe
by John Cusack or some celebrity uh
about politics and then you would get to
me and it would be like you know here's
a great recipe for lemon squares and
then an hour later I would post
something like I found this in my yard
it looks like a g-string does this
belong to and I would mention the names
of the people on The Huffington Post so
it was almost like
you know what it was it was like a
bulleted board at a dormitory so it was
all these lost and found things
complaints uh get-togethers later like
Byron York's gonna have a get-together
at his place it was to create a fantasy
of something that really didn't exist
did you did you bring that to Fox or
like are you the guy that brought that
because that is one of the things you do
it all the time you make fun of
everybody that's on the network they
make fun of you and you can see you guys
genuinely like each other
on CNN when it would be lemon handing it
to Cuomo it was like YouTube despise
each other and what did they say I love
you yeah I love you man yeah I love you
man and it's like it was so clear they
would sue each other into Oblivion given
the chance but it was it's this it's the
secret sauce of I I think success or
chemistry the secret sauce to chemistry
is the ability to tease people and I've
been doing this all my life I get
accused of being mean because of like
people who don't understand the
relationship between me and kill me I
love kill me yeah it's great because
because kill me
is the perfect foil like he he just he's
just always like what are you doing and
it's like and I would make fun of him
it's because I really I I love his hit
the fact that he's impervious and so we
get along a lot of people go that Greg
is this really mean to Brian Kilmeade
he's really mean to cat and it's like
cat writes the introductions that I use
but the thing is if you see me not
teasing somebody it's because they're
not worth it or they're so thin skinned
it's not even like I don't want to get a
call later saying like so and so
appreciates that you just leave her or
him out of it I won't say who these
people are but there was like one female
who's no longer at Fox who had her own
show who even I even I even apologized
to her her name's not doesn't rhyme with
Moretta bran lustern but it could be I
think I got it uh yeah I even apologized
to her and she called me an awful human
being and blah blah blah but I realized
like there's some people who have been
in I don't know in this cloistered world
so long that they're not used they're
not used to somebody saying a joke about
them or or uh and I think the only thing
I said that was mean to her bad about
her was I it was a softball interview
with Trump that was it and it was just a
silly joke and she man she was pissed so
I learned that like okay steer clear of
the humorless people I don't want them
around me but the people that I really
like I will tease them till the end of
time because to me that's the only way I
can express affection I'm not that I'm
not good at the other ways of doing it
so uh it's like when I first the five
kicked off quickly because I made fun of
Dana like Dana had Dana was in a world
where nobody made fun of her right and I
I we were we were seated together for
height reasons because you know when
you're when you're planning a show it's
all about the lighting and you can't
have me seated next to I don't know
Jesse because he's tall and I'm short so
she's like this I'm like this I'm
actually more like this and so we
receded together and it was like being
next to the serious homeroom girl except
that you you could tell that she she was
fun there was something going on in
there and she was never allowed to let
go
so I just started and I don't even know
what I was doing I was making fun of her
but in a kid brother sort of way and uh
and that was that was the immediate
thing that kind of got picked up and
meanwhile you know there's Beckel who's
hilarious ripping out everybody but
anybody who wasn't
amenable to teasing never lasts because
they can't handle it and they think like
oh my God you made a joke about me on
camera I need to be outraged it's like
no you don't the moment you laugh and
come back everybody loves it no and and
to your credit I'll say something nice
about you man we we've done it on your
show where you'll make a gay joke about
me and then I make a short joke about
you and it's like we're not angry it's
so like these people that are just
looking for everybody to be pissed but
do you think that is that in a weird way
more than anything the secret to what to
you becoming the king of late night like
it seems so weird to me like Johnny
Carson was the king of late night and
now it's Greg Gutfeld that just it's
just so insane you're gay
after 10 o'clock on weekends yeah I mean
I know you're married to a guy named
Dave I
thought this was all just a way to get
identity points d-e-i-e-s-g pretty
clever my straight friend it's a miracle
you did it on your own it was a long but
it was a long it was a long game uh yeah
I think so I think that um
uh
there's a bit of coziness with the
celebrities uh uh when you bring a
celebrity on they're like in this cage
and I don't like to do that like uh
we're gonna have this person come out
he's got a movie out don't ask him about
the divorce don't ask him about uh you
know his kid being picked up for drug
you have to talk about the movie I can't
I can't do that because that's like you
know Jay Leno was like think about Jay
Leno with uh who was the British actor
bro was that famous one the the Hugh
Grant thank you yeah I think around 92
yeah yeah and he said something like
it's funny how you know the exact date
Dave yeah I I um
no maybe we might have been 95. Google
here on The Tonight Show I think it was
right the name of the hooker she had a
really cool name
she had a cool name like Daisy or
something she was beautiful beautiful
black girl we'll get it I don't have 12
staff members but I've got somebody with
a computer in this room right now and
I'm gonna find out what year was Hugh
Grant on The Tonight Show with Jay Leno
95 95 I did it and what was the hooker's
name what was the hooker's name yes
Daisy Dottie Daisy Doreen
Doreen Doris Delilah Delilah Devine
Brown divine
you see what happens Greg we're at the
age you're a little older than me but
we're at the age where you basically
just have to point to people to ask them
things what happened that day you know
they weren't even alive but I think that
is like the kind of um it is the whole
point if you're gonna the show is no
different than having people over in
your living room yeah and and so the
people at home get to know everybody
better because they get to know the real
you if I'm making fun of you and you're
making fun of me they learn more about
us than they would if you had showed up
on any other show now you could argue
and I'm sure someone would make the
argument Greg if you had um Hollywood
celebrities on your show your ratings
would be higher I don't buy that at all
because we're beating them yeah um and
Carson and Letterman they were different
I mean they would he Carson
which is the next step he had big stars
and they would just rip each other some
of them would be drunk incredible Dean
Martin and Sinatra oh my God
Reynolds like you go on to a Dom and
yeah yeah yeah no it was great and and
so I I think you know I I feel like the
people that I have on my show are stars
in their own right
do you think it's kind of
um I guess weird or bizarre that you're
on a Cable News Network where everyone
is watching you waiting to destroy you
at any given moment you do a more a
little bit more of a straight thing on
the five but you know you're you're
yourself but the show is a little let's
say a little more straighter more than
it's weird because
it's
um the irony is
dangerous on Gutfeld they leave me alone
right but if they it's the people that
are really trying to get me are the ones
that are auditing and I use that like
auditing the five so they're actually
like it's like they're not taking the
course you know they're showing up in
the back right I mean that the professor
uses the wrong pronoun and that's that's
what that's what I I notice that it's
more like so you know like uh you know
I would assume that at least once a week
there is somebody deliberately trying to
destroy my career but I can't let that
stop me I have to I I've talked about
this in previous books we all have to
share the risk and I will I and I have
to always I I'm not blowing smoke up
your ass but I have to say that you
helped destroy cancel Culture by
monetizing the act of being canceled
if you get canceled and there's another
way out you will always rise above uh
the perfect example is Jason Aldean yeah
getting Target his song goes to number
one there are a lot of other things and
then there's up then there's the reverse
that if you try to be the opposite of
cancel culture that is woke that will
have an effect like the Bud Light thing
where that is actually people not social
media but people going you know what I
don't like that they're trying to sell
me something that's so fake and it's it
and and they and by the way the consumer
had to be educated on why Bud Light did
that Bud Light was trying to uh Supply
their brownie points for
yeah it wasn't it had nothing to do with
the consumer and so it meant let's make
fun of the consumer
and so the consumer's like going like
why is this happening they get educated
they're going like well screw them
there's a shitload of beer out there I
can drink it doesn't have to be Bud
Light
what do you mean like go ahead no no no
no you go you're the guest continue
I already forgot what I was going to say
you were gonna make a you were really
gonna bring home the Bud Light point I
think you were going to connect it to
Target here's the thing here's the thing
uh I don't believe that that boycotts
are good however I think that when you
see that somebody is trying to pull a
fast one on you
that's worthy enough to call it out and
to avoid them but and then when you see
somebody who's being unfairly targeted
that is when you share the risk and that
is when you go like okay I'm gonna go
buy Greg gutfeld's book because they
accused him of being a bigot or a racist
because I know he isn't I want to have
the Jason Aldean effect where it's like
oh so you said this you said a song that
has no black people in it that has no
lynching narratives is racist okay
you're trying to destroy this person I'm
gonna make this song number one
what's your policy on when you're
watching the Clips of the lunatics of
the view or the crazy people at the
televised mental institution of MSNBC
when you're prepping your show because I
have no doubt you're going through the
same thing I'm going through on one hand
I want these people to be ignored and
disappear and whatever on the other hand
they they are literally writing our
shows for us and I do think they have to
be exposed but I always have this little
internal struggle with how much
attention so what do we what do we do
with that Greg we monetize it I guess
it's like it's got you have to take a
tolerance break you know when like
people smoke uh let's say the herb uh
and you realize your your your uh
tolerance level's gotten so high uh you
need to like take a tolerance break from
uh gotcha videos
um when I look at the view clips
if there is a punch line for me exiting
it then I gotta use it because everybody
loves those clips and if you have a good
singer you put that in there uh and
that's fun A lot of people do it
themselves on Twitter you know they'll
tweet something go I can't believe this
whatever but it's not if if if I have
that clip of you know Joy Reid like I
got bored with Joy Reed because
everything was the same thing and I
realized maybe I'm helping her
but if I got a really good comment
coming out of that uh that I know it's a
Surefire laugh uh then you have the
evidence there uh you don't have to set
up the joke the joke is there it's like
it's like a it's free money as they say
yeah since you're on the corporate side
of this so to speak you work at a
corporation it's a big Corporation one
of my things lately has been like when
I'm making fun of Joy read it's like to
me it's like I don't know if at this
point she's a willful idiot or just or
if she's genuinely the racist lunatic I
think she is but I keep thinking isn't
this really about not just the producers
above her so like the EP in charge of
her but the exec in charge of that guy
and then really all the way up like can
you just talk a little bit about
corporate structure in cable news
because I think people I think people
are wondering about that like they know
every day they put her on air or they
put any of these people how do they do
that how can they do that but then when
they're when you're I'm sure over in
their territory they were saying the
same thing saying about Tucker or about
me or Jesse it's weird MSNBC is weird
because
excuse me I'm having three fluids yeah
and I put up four yeah um MSNBC didn't
start this way I mean if they had MSNBC
had Tucker Tucker's sidekick I think was
uh Rachel Maddow if I remember and they
also had yeah and I think they had
Charles Grodin oh they did have colored
they have Phil Donahue I mean he was a
lefty but not bananas yeah yeah so it
was it was at one point yeah they're a
judge so it was kind of like they were
finding their bearings and then this was
the beginning of the siloing where I'm
going to this side you're going to this
side and they saw a monetary possibility
and creating a silo specifically for
that and then what happens is and it's a
it's a destructive incentive and you
have to be careful with it that you will
be rewarded the the more certain you are
not not the more outrageous you are but
the more certain you are about your
position I have never been one to be I
don't like the idea of attitude and I
think you're the same way it's like it's
like
it feels good to be wrong it's like it's
it's like a great feeling like I've had
this you know this you know come to
Russell Brand moment with him where it's
like you know I was a dick to him and he
was a dick to me I was addicted to Glenn
Greenwald he was a dick to me but you
it's like it feels really good to
realize yeah I was I screwed up they
might have screwed up but I might have
screwed up more but it's like if you are
just that person every single day that
comes in and goes
this is the most outrageous story I've
never been more outraged in my life it
is the worst I don't even know there was
one person talking about me that said I
had to step away from the TV when I saw
remember the line entrepreneur was here
I'm literally I'm literally shaking I'm
literally shaking as I tweet this
because this man is so disgusting so
it's like it's that sort of thing uh in
this incentivized world of outrage that
just creates more clicks and makes more
money and I think what happens is you
might not even notice it
it's interesting when you see like
people who get fired
and they end up somewhere else and they
change so maybe Chris Cuomo is now a
news Nation he's probably not the Chris
Cuomo at CNN I know he suddenly sounded
a lot more like us not that anyone's
watching but like yeah exactly exactly
and I think you're going to see that
with Don Lemon uh stelter the people
that were that put on the costume then
take it off I don't think I think belter
was wearing a fat suit is that what
you're telling me good boy could you
imagine if that I mean my goodness could
you imagine if he wore a fat suit yeah
yeah that's an expensive fat suit yeah
let me ask you let me ask you some
serious hardcore questions you ready
yeah you live in New York you sick freak
you live in New York City blue blue blue
blue blue uh you were there during kovid
I remember you were texting me pictures
as all hell was breaking loose literally
outside of your apartment uh what is
going on with New York City now and uh
you do you feel like it's ever gonna
turn around we're going hardcore now for
a few minutes
I think there's a sense of giving in
which is the same as giving up I notice
on Mondays and Fridays there's not a lot
of people in the city and it has nothing
to do with weather or holidays the
people that can afford to leave leave so
really
New York for a lot of people is three
days and and I I I come in I I go to the
I have a cabin about an hour and a half
away and I come in Monday and it's
amazingly fast and it's like there's
nobody on the road there's tons of
parking
and then on Friday it's like oh I'm
gonna hit a lot of traffic when I leave
work on Friday you don't because
everybody left on third nobody's there
so I think what's happened is instead of
trying to improve the city the people
just reduce their presence in the city
and so you still have it's strange how
the sadness and the depression of a city
has moved to Midtown it's not like the
Lower East Side right right it's
actually where people work because
there's fewer people there and so that
when you have less foot traffic you have
more bad things and I know that
everybody says oh the broken windows
theory has been debunked not really I
mean when they keep arresting people
that that do little things and you find
out they're wanted for big things maybe
that it's there but I think that like
you have graffiti uh you have theft and
it just gets worse and then pretty soon
you have I have this weird all I see on
the streets when I'm driving up on the
city from like I'm so blow up
I see if I pick an age group say the 35
year old human being women they're all
in Lululemon going to their yoga or
Pilates classes they're just walking
the men strung out now I'm eliminating
I'm eliminating tourists and UPS and
FedEx
it's strange how the men have become
thoroughly uh almost emasculated by
drugs they're kind of just they're
they're sad they're depressing but
they're almost not harmful except for
the ones that will beat the out of
you or put you in front of a subway
train but it's like but then you except
for those except for those it's a small
exception but you see women uh and
they're going to work because it's
almost like you walk like what's this
strung out fentanyl laced guy gonna do
to me and you like the worst and so they
take up the bust the bus stops they
sleep in there it's all there so that so
you have all these little middle-aged
women who are going to do their maid
jobs having to stand you know on the
side but it's almost all drug-induced
men a drug-induced men uh drug adult men
and women getting to their exercise
classes that's to me that to me
describes Sixth Avenue what do you make
of that I know you're a Jordan Peterson
guy and you you pay attention to all
this stuff and what do you make about
like what's happening to young men as a
guy that like was writing a men's
magazine and editing a men's magazine
and all that I I would say just off the
top of my head men are more inclined to
take risks which is why they're more
into drug abuse women when they run into
problems tend to look for help whether
it's self-help books or exercise so in
this weird time you see a lot more women
exercising and a lot more men abusing
substances I think that might be the
thing and because there's so many men
that are
like they're not the same kind of
criminal of they're not like in the
crack epidemic uh violent or dangerous
because they're too strung out and
there's there used to be this belief
that their drugs were being spiked with
fentanyl and it turns out they're
looking for it I I that totally blew my
mind when I first heard that because I'm
going there's no way because I've known
I I've known three people personally
that are dead from Fentanyl and they
weren't taking it on purpose oh wow but
but when you talk to those in the know
with drugs no they're like fentanyl is a
desired it's not it's like the drug
dealers wouldn't put it in there if they
weren't making money so there is a
desire for that next level pie and I
think you're seeing that on the streets
I think that there is a hole for meaning
and I think that people are filling it
in the weirdest ways and women are on
their own and men have kind of abdicated
their role in society I don't know if it
has something to do with culture or what
but it's I kind of sense that that like
you know we've retreated into our own
camps
so when you see that in the city I mean
you know I freaking left La I used to
live in New York City so now I'm here in
the Free State of Florida where it is
just booming and flourishing and it's
hot but it's okay it's the price to pay
for Freedom like I see all the goodness
here do you do you see any way out for
the city itself the people you're
talking about all that I would I mean
I think that it's like oh God it's like
a marriage okay so it's like you have a
husband and a wife
and each and they're different and they
have to each bring their different tool
set to the marriage and you're missing
the dad
so
what the woman brings is the compassion
and the caring and all that stuff
but without the dad there's you have
people aren't in jail
prisons are closing you can walk in
anywhere and take anything you want I
feel like they're needs and this is do
you pay for things that uh Duane Reade
or you think you just take whatever you
want yeah I take whatever I want this
this laptop I just walked out of and
these these are not even mine I took
these from an elder an elderly woman at
a bus stop just ripped him off her head
and uh and then I told her to buy my
book and she did and she did she ordered
it on her laptop before I took her
laptop
the analogy is imperfect but what I'm
saying what I'm trying to say is there
needs to be some sort of uh uh yin and
yang relationship between the carrot and
the stick and Republicans were always
the stick and Democrats have a hard time
being the stick because they're supposed
to be the carrot and so they like the
moment you have a Democrat like I don't
know mayor Adams talking about
Justice and or prison time his whole
side turns on him you need a republican
so it's like there it you need to have
the carrot in the stick the husband and
the the wife you need to have these or
the husband and the husband
uh in your case Dave and Dave which one
of you is the stick and which one of you
is the carrot have you ever thought
about that
Greg can we take this off uh yeah we'll
take it off I'm interviewing you I mean
come on what are you doing here you wait
till next time I'm on your show then you
can ask me the questions
let's talk politics you want to talk
politics for a little bit
give me 10 10 minutes I'm supposed to be
I'm five you get five minutes because I
gotta change and I gotta go to work okay
we'll even do it quicker than that I'm
trying to deal with this Trump DeSantis
nonsense everyone's angry everyone's
fighting obviously I I love descendants
I see what he's done in Florida I voted
for Trump I like Trump I like his kids
but all hell is breaking loose
everyone's trying to kill each other
your take and how are you dealing with
it publicly and all that stuff
we know what we're seeing and
unfortunately there may not be no way
out that there is
of very little possibility that Trump
won't be the nominee and there's a
strong possibility that he will lose so
we kind of know that and I've I've
raised this question to people that I
that approach Trump people and like how
can you reconcile this and they go well
the polls aren't telling the whole story
and I go well I don't know man it's like
Democrats
want him to be the nominee that's the
red flag for me because and it's not
Trump's fault it's the fact that there
is a faction of people that hate him so
strongly that they will put in the
effort yep you know you got if it's they
say it they say it every day if it's 30
of the population that despise him
they're gonna feel like 90 and I and I
know that like to say that you're not
going to counter that seems like you're
giving in
but if you've got other candidates that
could win it's not and that's the thing
it's like and I I I I I think Trump is
amazing and hilarious but it's like I I
would say dude like
this is gonna like I don't see I I see
you getting obviously getting the
nomination but I don't know how you're
gonna win because these dip it's being
set up so that you will lose so that's
my that's my take
I think that's all you're going to get
Dave do you have anything else you want
to say Greg before you go to work
whatever that is I don't know what I'm
doing I love you Dave that's what I'm
going to say and uh if you haven't got
my book no if you haven't bought my book
uh it's still available somewhere and uh
you don't have to buy it but I would
love it if you did and uh you'll you
should be on my show very soon I hope if
not I will this is over for that
craptastic City in September when I'm
back on the grid and we will do a show
and then uh what do you say we go out
and get drunk after huh yes no sex with
monkeys goodbye Greg see you later if
you're looking for more enlightening and
maybe even humorous conversations check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell